hello the Internet I'm Gavin Dunn and in
this very special video we've been set a
challenge by YouTube all those memes you
get on the internet well we thought we'd
try and recreate those will our own epic
slow-motion twist
bloody yeah Oh No
how's it delicious actually really good
yeah I want to get its wish I don't need
to be like clunk in I want to select
nothing but net to get in so if it's
just if it is late literally light hits
the thing and bounces out
that's my forget it casual flick okay
you did pretty well it's not reacting at
all is YouTube like did not maintain my
cool yeah
the whole point is deal with it you do
that I didn't really didn't deal with it
and there's a good
I was spelling
I still got water in my ear hole from
that next up we're going to do come at
me bro and I think we're going to fire
at the wind machine and have some
Fitness on the face
or is it a kind of way to see the budget
that someone cut the cake at my lip
concentrate being like come on man I've
been hit by bouncy ball how can we ruin
this really nicely laid out table we
could do the the tablecloth whip yeah
dive through it headfirst dive through
headfirst get some good sliding action
on it or just flip the entire thing just
flip the whole thing up into the air
good great that is a mess you really
didn't like that champagne
I didn't just stay the same
high school that's the biggest message
we did now this looks like you're angry
in the road so for this up we have two
lovely crash mats two springboards never
look and a vat of balls of that good
word so these are just going to go
absolutely everywhere dan can we to get
you fondling the balls again please
excellent can we just quickly talk about
something for a second this is your
crash mat yeah that you're gonna walk
along yeah lovely and rich Neil
delicious look at this one it's like
it's like I'm literally a pile of bricks
right throughout and blue plastic
oh I definitely felt some connection you
know I don't know why hit in the Hat I
think we did hit hands yeah
there are incoming high five okay yeah
I'm trying that yeah there was some food
addiction you came through
hey my face it looks majestic
the sleeves over your face
version of rooster we make attractive
faces when we get the ground
thanks for watching that video you can
find all the gifts from this video over
there by Dan no yes right here meant to
do that so
you